le nom de la victime lé o copernic est
victime été tuées dans le local à
costumes
ensuite à les déplacer
c'est une sorte de mise en scène
isoler
combien de temps pensez-vous encore
devoir nous regarder l'idée est elle la
rassembler tous les suspects puis nous
interroger à tour de rôle jusqu'à ce que
le mystère soirée zouk mervyn qu'aucun
magistrat nature estime dramaturge trust
inc vous me voyez désolé j'ai du mal à
relire mon écriture et
il ya eu un incident
tueraient pour ça c'est une confession
ne tirons pas de conclusions hâtives
pour une surprise si vous travaillez
tard
ou le statut et copernic pour dissimuler
son aventure on a notre tueur au pardon
j'ai encore fait j'ai tiré des
conclusions hâtives
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler de
richard attenborough un véritable
enquêteurs
y avait-il une raison particulière à
cette animosité
[Musique]
c'était moi inspecteurs je vous arrête
pour le meurtre de lyon nous avons un
tueur en série en liberté
ole reculé
[Musique]
sous le paillasson
nous ne sommes plus seulement des
suspects
nous sommes ici
potentiellement des victimes
qu'at-il fait qui vous a semblé suspect
n'était pas ton ce qu'il faisait mais
c'était plutôt le bel à la façon dont
ils faisaient groves et il te façon
suspecte bien